me connaissez mon visage friponne
rappelé à cette occasion vos sens
défrayer et c'est à contrecoeur qui si
vous me voyez je trouve lancé projet
l'amour qui vous précède
j'appelais poids des yeux galante
m'entraîne il est trop peu éloigné pour
porter secours à un si jeune encore vous
jouez de ces sources votre simplicité
qui semble s'emparer demande s'ils ont
fait des enfants parlaient et vous savez
donner des rendez-vous la nuit et
poursuivre un galant vous évaluez sans
bruit du vieux comme avec lui votre
langue cajole il faut qu'on vous ait
misé à quelques bonnes écoles qui dit on
retrouve tout d'un coup vous un attentat
prix vous ne craignez non plus de
trouver les esprits et se galant la nuit
nous adorons grand art d'irak aussi en
venir à cette perfidie malgré tout mais
bien fait fournir un tel dessein petit
serpent que j'irai chauffer dans mon
sein et qui dès qu'il se sent par une
humeur à un grade cherche à faire du mal
à sa bulle il flatte pourquoi le clic et
vous les grandeurs en effet sinon tout
moi demain tout ce que j'ai suivra alors
n'est pas une action à femmes
c'est un homme qui dit qu'il me fait
pour sa femme je suis vivre le saut et
vous m'avez précieux qu'ils se sont
mariés pour ôter le pays oui mais pour
femme moi je prétendais comprendre je
roulais réfrène me semble assez
imparable
oui mais ça vous parler franchement
entre nous il est plus pour cela c'est
le bon goût que vous chez vous les
mariages est fâché c'est pénible et vous
discours en font une image terrible mais
là il le fait lui si remplie de plaisir
que de se marier il donne des désirs
c'est que vous l'aimez traîtresse oui je
laime et vous avez le front de l'est
j'ai en moi même pourquoi tu il est vrai
ne dirige pas vous deviez vous n' est
impertinente
c'est ce que jean puy mais lui seul en
est la cause des jeunes y songez pas
lorsque ce fait la chose visitera les
chasseuses et amoureux désir le moyen de
chasser ce qui fait du plaisir
sa vie nous pacser thème déplaire ouais
point du tout quel mal c'est là vous
petit faire il est vrai les sujets dans
les frères réjouit vous ne m'aimez non
pas à ce compte
oui non comment voyez-vous aisément
pourquoi pas mais mais madame la plus
lente ont dieu ce n'est pas moi que vous
devez bien mais que ne vous êtes vous
comme lui fait aimer je le veux dans les
pas empêché que je pense je me suis
efforcé de toute ma puissance
mais les soins que j'ai pris je les ai
perdus tous vraiment il enseigne la
discipline que vous car se faire aimer
la pointue de pelle voyez comme résonne
mais répond la vilaine peste